What are the two signs of many that the
Lord gave me when it came to the
Catholic Church? Okay, let me You'll say
it's subject. That's fine.
The one sign when Mike's wife did what
she did and served me divorce papers and
then got me out of my home. It was
November 2017,
Thanksgiving. First Thanksgiving without
my daughters, man. Is she evil, dude?
Say, "Pray God heal my heart, guys. Pray
God heal me of my bondage. I'm in
bondage to lustful impurities, food
addiction. Pray for a miracle of the
Holy Spirit. Crush, destroy these
chains, set me free to be holy and pure.
Protect this young woman. She stays
pure. God, forgive me for being a
stumbling block to her. She's a good
woman. All right?
And pray God heal my heart because when
I think what she did, I need healing.
Cost me my daughter. Nonetheless,
that thanksgiving and I've shared in the
past. I'll just give you the script.
We're going to get into the topic. That
Thanksgiving, I had nowhere to go. So, I
wanted to go to
a restaurant to eat. There were several
sisters that joined me. One went to be
with the Lord. Her name is Shemi Shamir.
She went to be with the Lord. Her sister
is still with us. She's alive. Her name
is Moren. She watches me. She's a
witness. She was there. She See, I got
witnesses to what I say. So, you guys
don't think I'm lying.
also a sister named Patty. Also a sister
named Michelle, an Iranian convert to
Christianity. They joined me. Now I
wanted to go
I believe I wanted to go to Boston
Market. No, no, I didn't want to go to
Boston. Sorry. I wanted to go to Panera,
but it was closed Thanksgiving. And if I
recall, I wanted to go to Rizzo's
restaurant that was closed. The only
thing that was open was IHOP,
International House of Pancakes.
So, I told them we met there. Now, as I
got there,
I was in the car,
several cars down, there was a little
white car, two ladies sitting there.
Miracle.
And as I get older, I hope I don't
forget the details, but I mentioned this
in the past. So, it's recorded, but you
get older, your memory is not what it
used to be. But I'll give you the gist.
So, I got out. They got out. There were
two ladies. They're both up in age, but
one was older than the other. So, it was
mother and daughter. They sat. I walked
in. We sat near the back. The sisters
came. We're talking. I think within an
hour in the conversation, I turned and
they're standing right to my right, both
of them. The younger of the two looked
at me smiling because we're talking
about Christ. We're talking about
Thanksgiving, talking about my
situation. The younger the two, and
Moren, she'll be listening. A sister of
the Lord, she was there. Michelle was
there. Patty was there. They still
remember it. So, I'm not lying.
She sat and she was looking at me
smiling. She goes, "Oh, you know what?
We were not listening, but we were
listening." meaning they were e
earropping. Is it called ears dropping?
Eve I don't know what's the term. And
she goes, "I can't believe it." Oh, the
words coming out of your mouth about
Jesus Christ. Wow. We're in awe. She was
shocked because we're talking about
Christ. Eavesdropping. Yeah. I thought
it was eavesdropping, but I never knew
why eavesdropping.
That makes sense. Ears dropping sounds
better. All right.
So because they heard us talk about
Christ, they were [snorts]
glued in, fixed.
So I told them my story, the older
woman, her mother, you know what she
says to me? She says, "I'm part of an
email, a group, an email group, and if I
remember," she said there were thousands
of people on email.
If I remember, it was in the hundreds of
thousands. Maybe I'm wrong, but I know
it's thousands. We are prayer warriors
who intercede and we all pray the
rosary.
And we're going to add you and your
daughters to our list and pray for you.
That's sign number one.
Rosary
sign number one.
Okay.
I mentioned it. I mentioned the story
about two years ago.
November 2017, Thanksgiving.
Okay. What rosary? That's one. Okay.
They told me they were not planning to
come to IHOP. They wanted to go to
Boston Market, but it was too packed and
they had no choice to come to IHOP. Now,
who do you think orchestrated that?
Who do you think orchestrated that?
They were going to go somewhere else
but ended up where I was at at the same
time I was there. Second miracle. They
were going to go into the Islamic
dilemma so I can finish the series.
Right.
Second miracle.
Second miracle. They're going to go into
the series.
I used to go to St. Lamb Lambert's
Catholic Church in Skoi.
Father Richard Simon who's now retired.
He was the priest. He still does
relevant radio. Let me find it for you.
A very humble man, a godly man. Loves
the Lord. And he was part of the
Catholic Charismatic Movement. He's now
retired, but he has a show Monday
through Friday on Relevant Radio. I love
the man. Very humble man. I used to go
to his Bible studies on Thursday. All
right, let me find them. Father Richard
Simon. You guys, if you're on Relevant
Radio, he's on it.
Here he go. Here he goes. This man here.
He retired. He's no longer the priest of
that church, but this is him right here.
Father Richard Simon, Relevant Radio.
There he goes. That's him. I love this
guy. When I say guy, I mean it
respectfully. I'm not attacking him.
He'll He's just brilliant, humble,
Christlike, devoted. I pray that I'm
spiritual and not carnal and I practice
what I preach. God has done miracles for
him and through him. Nonetheless, I
would go to his Bible studies on
Thursday. In fact, one Thursday he
didn't show up. I started teaching. But
in one particular Thursday, there was a
lady sitting there
and I asked him a question. I didn't
teach. I didn't debate. I wasn't there
to debate. I was there to learn. I asked
them a question. Now that's Thursday,
right? Part of my journey part of my
journey included the church doors were
open every day. So I would go every day
go before the altar and pray to the Lord
and ask the intercession of the blessed
mother.
I went Sunday forgetting there's mass.
Now watch that Thursday there was a lady
sitting. She heard me ask the question.
Sunday, listen to this miracle. Sunday.
I go, there's mass. I wait
to leave so I can go pray by myself.
As I'm waiting, the lady comes out with
two of her sons and her husband.
Her the older of the two sons looked at
me in shock. Told you a story. He goes,
"You're you're Sam Shimoon. I can't
believe it. I follow you in David Wood."
Because we used to do Jesus or Muhammad.
Yeah, that's me. He couldn't believe it.
He goes, "Man, I read your articles
answering Islam." The mother then looked
at me. She goes, "Now I see why you're
so knowledgeable." I swear to you,
that's what she said to me. I'm not
lying. I go, "How can you decipher I'm
so knowledgeable?" She goes, "That
Thursday when you asked that question, I
knew that you had knowledge." I go,
"Just from a question?" I swear I was
like shocked. Just from my question,
you could tell from my question that I
had not. She goes, "Yeah, all right. I'm
going to tell you the miracle with the
young boy." But then I told them my
story what I do. You know what she tells
me now? Second miracle, right?
Yeah. You are. You are a liar. I'm going
to prove that you're a liar right here.
Okay. Because you're a son of Satan. You
won't stop manifesting. Exactly.
Does the Catholic Church
give communion
to baptized and confirmed
members of the Assyrian Church of the
East?
What does it say guys?
Yes, the Catholic Church permits
baptized confirmed members of the
Assyrian church east to receive holy
communion provided they requested on
their own and properly disposed and
cannot easily approach a minister of
their own community due to recognizing
valid apostolic succession and
sacraments and the Assyrian church. The
Catholic allows this often case of
necessities
is the Assyrian church in communion with
the council of the Cath. Assyrian church
was one of the earliest to separate
itself from communion with the Catholic
church. It traced its origin to the sea
of Seusia deson so by St. Thomas the
apostle as well as St. Mari and St. Ad.
Yeah. But can you tell us there can we
we already know they are?
Let's see.
I don't even know what this is saying.
Yeah, see, sometimes it's even
misleading because we just read the
Vatican document there, partial
communion. Nonetheless, anyway, sorry
about that distraction,
the miracle. You ready for the miracle?
You guys ready for the miracle?
Everyone ready for the miracle? They
came out. The young boy recognized me
because he's been following me. David
Wood reading articles answering Islam.
The mother says, "See now, now I see why
you have knowledge. You know, you have
knowledge." Okay.
I told her my story. Second miracle. She
goes, "There's a group of ladies and me.
We meet in the church every Monday
and we pray the rosary and intercede for
people. We're going to add you to our
intentions
when we gather on Monday and intercede
as we pray the rosary. Second miracle
with the rosary
in connection with the Catholic Church.
Now let me tell you a story of the young
boy. He goes, "I have a Muslim friend
I'm witnessing to. Could I bring him?
Could you meet him answer his
questions?" I go, "Sure." I gave him my
number.
Over an hour later, he came. I answer
his questions about the Trinity.
Several weeks later, the young boy
called me. He says, "My friend wants to
meet you. We met at Starbucks on
Dempster Avenue
by Skoi." Is it Skooki or Crawford?
I believe. Yeah, there is a Starbucks.
If you're from that area, there's a
Starbucks between Skoi and Crawford on
Dempster Avenue. We met after I finished
answering these questions in front of
his friend. He goes, "Now I'm convinced
of the Trinity and I I believe Jesus
Christ is Lord." And he confessed Jesus
as his Lord and Savior.
young Catholic boy witnessing to his
Muslim teenage friend.
Okay. So, these are the things that God
confronted with. The signs that God
confronted with. Now, one more sign I'll
give you that goes back to my childhood.
You ready? Goes back to my childhood.
You ready for my
other sign that goes back to my
childhood?
Raymond Malco, that nine-year-old that
preached to me the gospel of Jesus
Christ.
His grandmother
who now is with the Lord Jesus Christ,
she is a Syrian from Lebanon. She's part
of the Catholic Church. As
[clears throat]
a 6 and a half yearear-old, she taught
me the A Mariah.
Do you see the signs that God is
surrounding me with? They're all
Catholic related. A a
Maria
a a
So at 6 and a half she teaches me the a
Maria. She's part of the Catholic
church. Assyrian Lebanese. What do they
call the Catholic church in Lebanon?
Melkite or Marinite? Anyway, you guys
know more than me. These two signs.
Okay. So this is why I said, "All right,
I'm going to take a step of faith.
That's it."
And then the Lord will confirm this is
where he wants me to be. Right? I don't
wait to get my theology perfected before
I take a step of faith. Silly, right?
But I'm also aware
that I need to be humble and fearful
and that
I may be misunderstanding the signs,
misreading them, but God sees the heart
and intentions and sees where you're at
and will take that into account and have
mercy and pity on you. And God has given
signs. He works with all these churches.